确实这部片子知名度比较高啊，这个评分也非常高啊。为什么选了这部片子呢？因为上次下课的时候，很多同学说没有拉印度片，然后没有拉体育片，印度加体育哎，完美是吧？
印度加体育加高分是吧？正好符合大家的要求，这个片子非常值得一看。这这部电影很显而易见啊，运动题材的呃这种类型的片子其实国内这几年也很多啊，经常有人拿给我看这样的剧本或者是这样的项目，我也可以剧透一下啊，国内最顶流的几个导演，还有演员啊。
都拿过教练类型的剧本给我看啊，都在他们计划内啊。所以说像这一类啊呃演员特别有发挥的空间，我们今天就学习一下这种类型电影的希望啊。那么我们先来看这部片子它有多少信息拍啊，嗯，再次强调一下啊，很多同学有时候会自己。
预袭电影的时候也会自己拉一下这节拍啊，我再给大家强调一下它的原则是什么啊？它的原则是带给一个观众，带给观众一个新的期待。大家记住啊，我们说一个故事呀，我们这个追本溯源啊，一个故事到了本身你还是要牵着观众走。
很多同学有没有这样的经历啊，就是你在当面给你的朋友或者给一群受众讲一个故事的时候，如果有一段讲不下观众明显走神了，你就会知道这一段是废型。故事的本质是永远牵着观众走。但是由于我们搞创作的时候，不管是电影也好，电视剧也好。
你看不到观众，对吧？你看不到观众的时候，你有时候就会肆意妄为。
你就会讲一些观众根本不想看的东西，不想听的东西，牵引不住观众的东西，这就是你的问题。我为什么说你看啊，我我很喜欢美国的一些脱口秀演员，因为美国的脱口秀演员全都坚职配电影。
为什么？因为他们在做喜剧的时候，他们特别怕失去观众，他们需要每时每刻有梗。
每一分钟都不能让观众走神。美国有很多这样的喜剧，凯哇哈特是吧？d于speelle是吧？这些喜剧演员都有做做影视，包括现在很火的黑人兄弟，我们说。
我们讲故事写剧本啊，时时刻刻记住啊，你是为观众服务。我在课上我在不同的教程里面都讲强调过这个问题，千万不要太自我啊，千万不要觉得我是搞艺术的啊。那么我们的节拍就是这么分的，能不能带给观众一个新的期待啊，能不能带给观众一个新的哎哦哦，原来是这样啊，求治愈。
哎，你看我们就算他是一个有效的信息。好，看一下这部这部电影是如何一步一步吸引我们的第一盘啊来到第一分钟，男主的一个出场啊，交代他的环境。我们说下来是交代主角和主角的环境的这部电影是一部印度电影啊，我们说印度电影有个特点啊。
它首先受西方影响也是比较明显的。但是呢它保留自己的民族传统也是非常坚决的啊，非常坚持。由于印度电影啊有大量的歌舞，我们说歌舞这个东西啊，它不是全世界通行的啊，所以说我们可以观察一下这部电影，它在歌舞处理方面的一些呃自己的技巧啊。
好，第一拍男主角一个出场先交代他的环境啊，他现在是一个普通的民间人士，看电视，看摔跤比赛。然后呢，他非常的希望印度能够拿到奖牌啊，希望自己的国家能够打拿到奖牌。这上来是一个主角的一个出场啊，第二拍呢第三分钟技能展示啊，配合电影的解说，他跟人比赛干什么摔跤啊。
展示他会摔跤这个技能。另外呢补充一下人设，交代一下他过往的经历啊。第三拍第6分钟开始开始训练一些小孩子啊，继续交代主角的缺失。他的缺失是什么呢？就是没有拿过国际奖牌。
对吧他是个全国冠军，但是没有拿过国际奖。简单说就是没有为国争光。因为什么年轻的时候被迫放弃了。听了父亲的话，我向先生妥协了。那他基于这个缺失，他就有一个梦想啊，就是想要一个儿子能够子承父业，为国争光。他的梦想是为国争光啊，梦想是为国争光。然后呢想要这个儿子呃想要个儿子，但是呢却生了个女儿。
到第四排啊，第8分钟为了生儿子，各种努力搞了一组蒙太奇啊。我们说印度电影蒙太奇很多，能理解为什么吗？第一，他们喜欢音乐啊，一配乐就忍不住。第二呢阿米尔汗也确实有钱啊，他拍电影镜头数非常多，碎的镜头特别特别的多啊，其实都很费钱的啊。
我们说一个镜头就是一场致景，就是一个钱呀。拍过戏的同学就知道这种蒙太奇有多费钱了，这就是有钱的电影和没钱的电影最大的区别。也就是说第四拍里面啊呃这个为了生儿子搞了一组蒙太奇各种努力嘛。结果第二胎还是女儿啊，因为他这里认他在这时候依然认为只有儿子能实现自己的梦想啊，他用台词说出来了。
我们说这部戏啊并不是虽然评分高，但我们凭常跟你说并不深奥，没是很显性的一些主题啊，没有什么深刻的东西，好吧，来第五拍。
来到11分钟，几年以后啊，他这个信念依然没有变，但是三胎四胎都还是女儿，导致他彻底放弃了，他放弃自己的梦想了，放弃自己的梦想标志性动作是什么呢？满墙的荣誉就吧全都收起来了，满墙的那些纪念啊。
奖牌呀、照片啊全都收起来了啊，这里有一个放弃梦想的动作，然后第六拍13分钟。
呃，被被找门子告状，我们北方话叫找门子啊，两个女儿在学校打男生，结果他发现女儿也能摔跤呀，也能继续梦想啊。我们说第六拍算是个激利事件，第七拍就开始召唤与拒绝召唤嘛。
第七拍15分钟必须说服自己的孩子的妈，对吧？然后带两个女儿训练一年。
包括跟他妈讨论女儿该不该为父亲的梦想放弃原本的人生这件事情进行了一个讨论。在这时候，他他的母亲认为女儿在为父亲的梦想牺牲自己的人生啊。
第八拍17分钟，带两个女儿吃最后一顿零食，开始训练，两个女儿非常崩溃，然后又来了一个BGM。这个但是我们强调一下啊，在这部电影当中嗯，阿米尔汗非常的克制，嗯，只放了欢快的印度音乐，但是一直没有跳舞啊除了婚礼那场戏，婚礼那场戏是合法跳舞。
同学们能理解啊，印度人拍电影他很难忍住，不不进行唱跳啊。但是在这部电影创作者非常克制，为了国际化嘛，为了国际票房啊非常的克制，忍不住跳舞就放在婚礼那场了啊，是为了国际市场啊，这很正常。第九拍啊，第九拍来到25分钟带着两个女儿。
和侄子一起训练啊，出战受挫出战受挫。
第十拍来了26分钟给女儿做肉吃啊，认为女儿没有力气是吃肉。因为这里要交代一下啊，印度大部分的印度普通家庭是吃素的，所以这里呢他比女儿吃肉呢，这个这个孩子的妈妈很崩溃啊，买鸡肉做鸡肉，他们吃素。那这件事情啊同学们我自己一直没有去过印度。
但其实我有个好朋友一直在印度工作，嗯，所以我经常问他啊，确实有这个情况，但是我一直搞不清楚，完全吃素，这身体能行吗？其其实就是想说这个父亲的决心很重啊，让孩子吃肉。嗯，很多故事啊，你要结合人家的社会背景去去看啊。好，来到第十一拍29分钟给女儿剃短发。
啊，给女儿剃短发，这是一个标志性的场景啊，让女儿剃了短发。我们说这场这场戏的作用是什么？好，我们说这场戏的作用是啥？为什么这场戏给女儿剃短发这件事情搞得仪式感这么重呢？甚至有一点像上路的感觉呀。对，肯定是正式启程，正式踏入旅途。
那我来问大家啊，短发代表什么？我们主角最开始的时候想要个什么男孩，我来提前说一下结论，你们按照这个结论再去重新给我看片子啊，记没记得？
我在课上给大家讲过主角的目标和他的行动的关系。假设主角的目标是泡妞儿，那他的第一个行动线是他认为泡妞需要跑车，他就需要搞个跑车。然后后来发现第二个行动线是ybe特慢，你当一个好男人，人家姑娘自然就喜欢你。
那么在这个故事当中，我们主角的目标是什么？为国争光，对吧？得国际奖牌为国争光，那他的第一个行动是什么呢？搞出儿子，所以他现在还在第一个目标里，把女儿当儿子，他要儿子。那你们大胆的设想一下，到故事后半段升华怎么生？
就是把孩子当女儿嘛，就是让女儿。
做自己嘛，所以你现在再去回回忆理解一下为什么最后一场爸爸根本没有出现，出现就主题就升不了了。很多同学非常遗憾说最后那场戏父亲为什么看不到，你现在去想一想是不是那场戏，如果他出现这个主题就实现不了。
因为在整个在这个电影里，他小主题是为国争光。同学们为国争光在这个故事里是小主题，大主题是什么？是不是男女平等？
对吧这个故事大主题是男女平等嘛。因为我们要结合印度女性地位这个这个这个现实情况，十四五岁就要嫁给一个陌生。所以这个故事大主题肯定是男女平等嘛，这样再去通盘理解一下。
一个故事，我们的主角在此刻定格这个镜头这里没有意识到男女平等的，你懂我意思吧？
他把女孩子的头发剃光，这不是对的做法。
虽然后面女儿也主动剃短了头发。
来表达自己对父亲的支持，但是剃光一个女孩子头发，并不是一个坚强的事情，并不证明这个女孩子坚强，这是错误的。把一个女孩子头发剃光，这个这没有什么可骄傲的。刚才讲的是第二幕第一场啊啊，第十一拍29分钟剃头发这个。
来12拍31分钟游戏时光，你既然要把女儿当儿子养，那女儿就开始各种反抗啊，用各种伎量逃脱训练啊，这是一个标准的游戏时光。
十三拍。
33分钟。
女儿呢偷偷打扮参加朋友的婚礼，一段合理的歌舞，终于展现了一下印度片的魅力啊，一段合理的载歌载舞啊，被父亲抓了。然后呢，在挨完揍之后，跟新娘的交流当中啊，那个两个女孩啊才知道。
自己身在福中，我们说故事是从这一刻才点出了男女平等的。B故事开始发力了。我们说进入第二幕之后，先有个仪式感的剃短发，仪式感的上路，然后又有游戏时光，女儿各种反抗，对吧？各种反抗，甚至参加朋友婚礼，这也是一种反抗嘛。
然后男女频前开始发力，也就是B故事开始了啊。我们说B故事不是人物的成长吗？我们说男主角一直想为国争光，包括整个故事的主题一直就是为国争光，没什么可成长的，成长的是什么啊？成长的是对女性的看法啊，所以说B故事在这里开始发力。
第十三拍参加朋友婚完婚礼才点出来男女平权，这14拍37分钟啊，这个分钟数我们就不谈了啊。由于这个每个人看的版本不一样，第二天开始主动训练啊，由于这个成长了嘛，开始主动训练，又一段训练蒙台奇又一段B尖啊，然后效果很明显，两个人战斗力提升，15拍39分钟。
呃，去参加摔摔跤比赛啊，经历了一个报名的艰难，然后比赛也很激烈，输了比赛，但是赢得了尊重啊，记不记得啊他选了一个最强的对手啊，16拍46分钟，女儿呢燃起了胜负欲啊，呃再次参赛，挑战男选手迅速成名，迅速成长，战胜成为了十力八乡的传奇人物吧啊。
也不能是传奇人物吧，十里八乡的名人啊，17拍49分钟呃去申请经费置办新场地啊，呃，这个女性呢不被看好，被歧视啊，在这里呢开始搞了一个开始搞这个对抗，主对抗开始了啊呃因为我们看到后半段知道呃，他们这个主要的绊脚石是是是体制啊，主要的绊脚石是体制里面那些。
那些人那些官儿，那些教练呃，回来之后只能用床垫啊，床垫模拟训练开始学习正式比赛的技巧啊，为正式比赛呃做准备了。18牌来到54分钟参加这个正式比赛，同时也慢慢长大了啊。几年以后了，两个孩子长大了，父亲也变老了啊，父亲变老变胖了。
然后呢。
成为了全国冠军。然后呢此时呢呃离父亲的目标接近了啊，就是为国争光。因为父亲的目标没有变，全国冠军没用，要为国争光，要走出国门十九拍啊，58分钟。
女儿。
要去国家体育学院继续深造了啊，要离开父亲了，去到一个全新的环境。但是呢这里的教练比较傲慢啊，否定运动员过去的一切，甚至把他爹撵走了。
20拍来到62分钟，女儿呢开始了丰富的大学新生活啊，也有点放飞自我了。父亲呢同时呃严格训练二女儿啊，两个故事两两条线平行，然后呢呃配合必健嘛啊，和大女儿渐行渐远，打电话都找不着了。21拍来到66分钟。
呃，长发的女儿回到了家，女儿已经蓄起了长发啊，非常标志性的蓄起了长发回到家呃，带回来很多新的东西啊，父亲看不惯新的一些习惯，新的一些战术，新的一些理念啊。然后两个人就比赛，女儿战胜了父亲啊，两个女儿当时当然这时候开始有分歧了啊。
一个坚持父亲，，另外一个坚持自我，坚坚持自我。
然后呃到这里呢，我们说呃故事的第一阶段是什么？故事的第一阶段是想把女儿当儿子养，实际上也就是想把女儿啊培养成一个呃那个那个男孩子，这里啊嗯得偿所愿，孩子现在确实很爷们儿，但是不跟你好了啊。
终点孩子不跟你好了啊呃你你的愿望达成了啊，虚假胜利，你不是想把他培养成一个是么？一个冠军吗？对吧？他现在成了，他也不理你了。好，22拍73分钟嗯，大女儿离开了啊，大女儿离开了。当然了，有同学喜欢把终点打的往前一点，认为他去到大学就已经离开父亲了。
也行，总而言之，你可以理解这几拍都是讲他离开父亲啊。
同学们能理解我说的也行是什么意思啊？就他离开父亲这几下都可以作为故事终点。因为人家写剧本的时候是不那么严格，非要拿尺量一个终点，就是在这儿，其实就是这一坨这意思离开啊把大女儿彻底走了，然后呢把大女儿培养成了自己，但也失去了女儿啊，把大女儿陪偿培养成了第二个自己嘛。
但是也失去了呃搞了一个煽情戏码啊，搞了一个煽情戏马，在22拍73分钟，23拍75分钟来了一个平行叙事啊，大女儿在国际赛事连连惨败，二女儿呢也获得了全国冠军，父亲呢高兴不起来，因为毕竟失去了一个女儿嘛。
然后24排78分钟，二女儿也去到体育学院，姐妹谈心，但是理念不合。
25拍79分钟，大女儿持续下滑啊，一直输被强烈看不起。26拍呢姐妹也又有谈心，81分钟，姐妹又谈心，劝说姐姐回归父亲怀抱。母亲呢也在那头劝说父亲，父女通了个电话，女儿道歉了，27拍84分钟。
女儿重新剪了短发啊，代表自己重新正错，回归父亲的指导。但是呢呃教练要求他降低级别争取奖牌，女儿反抗未果，28拍86分钟，父亲决定亲自到现场干预啊，来到大学附近租房子陪读，排除万难啊，制定了新的训练计划，29拍89分钟。
一切回到以前的样子，两个闺女每天早晨早起跟父亲训练，搞一组蒙太奇啊，搞一组蒙太奇，但是被教练抓包了，被教练抓住了30拍91分钟开除危机啊。呃，学学院决定开除父女，那肯定也会失去参赛资格嘛。然后父亲求情嗯女儿。
侥幸能留下来，但是彻底得罪了教练，父亲被禁止见女儿。我们说来到一个呃最危急的时。好，第四波31拍95分钟开始看视频远程指挥啊，父女心连心是打不断的啊，女儿继续接受指导进步明显。32拍99分钟，英联邦运动会开始比赛，啊，在父亲的指导下啊，晋级了半决赛，但是。
又进一步得罪了教练，33拍105分钟啊，教练和父亲的观点继续相反啊，他听父亲的很惊险，但是又赢了。
这个父亲积极备占，教练呢切取功劳，34拍115分钟决赛前夜。A呀呢搞了一个升华，我们说女儿开始成为了小女孩的榜样啊，我们说小女孩开始都以女儿为榜样了。教练虽然还在背后使坏，但是呢领导并不支持。在这里，父亲指出了明天的策略是什么？
我们说三十四拍把主题彻底点出来了。父亲第一个目标是把女儿当儿子养。第二，最后升华了之后，把是决定让女儿做自己。
不说这里。
看到主题了吧？
为什么我在第一幕的时候就告诉你们，这个故事的小主题是为国争光，大主题是男女平等。然后负责这个主题成长呢是我们的男主角，我们的男主角的意识到这一点。所以他在故事的本来的目标是为我争光。但他的第一个路径实实现目标的动作是什么？
搞个儿子，生了女儿，把女儿搞成儿子，我的女儿很像儿子，他很开心的，把我的女儿搞成儿子。错了。
后面那个目标是女儿就是女儿。
对吧我刚才说整个故事是个主题的时候，我相信有些同学会说老师有点过度解读啦。哎呀呀呀，怎么拔那么高呢？你现在看拔的高吗？
一点不过他说的比我还明啊。
很直白。
就是做你自己，做女性的榜样，为女性去战斗，不要做儿子了，我不要儿子了。这里我说把主题点的非常明确了啊。
为所有的印度小女孩去战斗，把主体升华了一下。来到第35拍，118分钟啊，决赛日，父亲呢被人诱骗锁了起来啊。我们说在最最后这个放了个大招啊，36拍，120分钟，比赛开始女儿找不到父亲啊，心里没底，比赛呢一度陷入被动，37拍127分钟，最关键时刻。
女儿想起父亲的话。
我们说在最关键的时候，永远想出想到最初的话，记不记得啊？同学们在最危急的时候，主角如果没有办法了，一定要想到最初的话，我在课上给大家讲过，想到最初最小时候别人给了你一本如来神掌，记不记得？
那你就这时候就该用了，想这时候不能想昨天父亲说的话了，想昨天晚上父亲说的话就就垮掉了，必须解读对对延时记门。很多同学记得是吧？想到小时候第一次猎气摔跤的时候，父亲对我说的话。
第一次必须是第一次。
而且第一次讲的时候就说过有个5分，有一种摔法能得5分，当时就有个伏笔。
对不对？力挽狂澜，好吧。
然后38拍132分钟啊，国歌奏响，我们说父亲不能来到现场看不到，也不知道结果。但是这里有一个巧妙的设计。国歌奏响，你就知道你女儿夺冠了嘛？印度国歌嘛，所以说这个国歌是穿透时空的这是一个非常好的设计，也激发了现场所有的女孩们，我们说这场戏由于他是印度国歌，我们听不懂。所以我们可能没有感受到。
这场戏设计的这个威力啊，如果是义勇军进行曲，同学们，你在这里绝对含毛这场戏是非常好的一场戏啊。
另外跟大家说一下啊，在这里当然国歌是非常振奋的，然后也激励了所有的小女孩，激励了大家的梦想。在这里再强调一个主题啊，我在课上给大家讲过，小主题套也一定要套大背景。这这个这里除了印度男女平权这个背景以外，大家知道英联邦运动会的毅义。
大家知不知道为什么在这个运动会里面，印度那么迫切的想要得金牌？
是大英帝国和他所有的殖民地国家搞得一场连欢。而在大英帝国和他所有的殖民帝国里面，印度国位置是什么？
净给人当管家，当仆人。
所以我们要在一个摔跤项目夺得金牌。
现在已经是独立的国家了呀，对不对？他有民族自尊心在里面，这种运这个运动会对于他们来说不亚于奥运，因为它有民族自尊心在里面，是1个14亿国家的1个14亿人口的老国家，也是一个拥有灿烂文明的国家啊。
确实他需要这个这一针兴奋剂啊。
39拍。
来到14034分钟。
嗯，女儿抛开记者和教练奔向刚刚赶来的父亲，把金牌给到父亲啊，实现父亲的愿望。我们说最后这场戏需要把金牌交到父亲手里，搞一个仪式感。我们说这是整个故事结构，我再强调一遍，同学们看懂了没有啊？
小主题是什么？为国争光，为国争光，两个行动路线。第一，搞个儿子出来，第二，女儿也行是吧？培养一个好女儿也行。所以说你看这是故事终点的分界地线啊，这线嘛。为了一个目标，两个行动线，我在课上讲过这种这种模型，同学们一定要学会这种写法啊。第二，整个故事的大主题或者是B故事成长线是什么呢？
成长线是认识到男女平等，然后包含的大环境呢，肯定还有一个英联邦的问题，以及还有隐藏一个同学们整个故事的主要对手是谁啊？
我们说从故事中断，其实不是中断了，第二幕就有申请经费，被驳被驳回。
整个故事的主要对手是关僚体系啊，关僚体系。我们说这也是这部片子啊，能够有有一定的深度啊的。
也是一方面啊嗯这让我想起来一句一件事情啊。同学们，我记得这部片子刚拍出来的时候，对吧？我记得有一个人不知道是一个领导还是一个什么人，在公共媒体上说过一句话，说中国的文艺创作者经常抱怨自己带着镣铐跳舞。
但其实他们是在找理由，你像印度电影摔跤吧，爸爸这种通篇全是正能量不好吗？你们为什么就写不出来？其实我当时就是很想反驳，摔跤吧，爸爸过不了过不了身差远了。
被毙无数次。
过不了，真过不了，你这不扯淡吗？主要对手是体制，每个人都给你十绊子，每一级的体育局官员都都是坏蛋，你这不扯淡吗？所以说我觉得有时候有些人他说话吧，或者他也是就扫了一眼啊，一知半解，这部片子怎么可能过呢？
对不对？然后有些同学说啊，他们愿意从女儿角度看这个故事，有没有这样的同学啊？
从女儿角度打点不是不行，但不太准。
因为女儿啊是一个从他区到自区的过程嘛，成长曲线也挺丰富。
但实际上整个故事还是讲的是父亲的愿望以及父亲的成长。
父亲扛的更多啊，即便是后半段后半段他去了体育学院之后，我跟你说，父亲也基本上没有超过2分钟不出场。好吧，所以说主角我们还是比较倾向于定位为父亲。然后呢这部电影还有一些特点啊，比如说蒙太奇比较多啊，配乐。
比较多，这个我们刚才讲过了是印度电影的一个特点，也是体育电影的一个特点。印度电影加体育电影双buff一叠加。我跟你说，这个蒙太奇就少不了了。然后这个电影还有一个问题啊。
煽情的台词啊。
还是比较多的，台词推进比较多。
经常一个话疗解决问题。像这种情况怎么办？或者说在这部电影里，为啥跟新娘的一段话？
以一个交谈理解了父亲，对吧？跟父亲的一个交谈，哎，实力就大增，这个怎么整？
我们说由于这个故事啊严格说是个传记体，他讲了父亲三个年龄段啊，三个年龄段的故事。
女儿呢也是两年免不了了。
没有办法在集中时空内搞太多冲突。有时候为了快速推进，免不了了。
那在这种情况下，我们再思考一个问题，这个电影凭什么评分这么高？
我们说它的主题挺显性的，叙事呢流畅是流畅，但是嘞哎台词推进也蛮多的，镜头数是多了，很很好看，很锦锣密鼓，眼花缭乱。但是是因为它有钱嘛，对不对？那这样的电影肯定是个好电影，但是评分如此之高，经常排在十大。
这个往平台的十大十佳里面，为什？我说有咱们就单纯从观众的角度探讨啊，就他凭什么搞了这么高的分儿？我觉得有几个原因啊，第一个原因观众爱打分的那帮人啊，对演员的付出看的比较重。
在这部戏里面，当年阿米尔汗为了这部戏减肥增肥跨度非常之大，这个是肯定是个原因。
我们说这肯定是个原因。
就演员付出很大，就像那个小李子拍得奥斯卡的那个电影，对吧？坦白说那个电影不咋地，能这么说吗？
荒野猎人不咋地能说吗？
对吧但是这个付出很多，就给了他一个奥斯卡这个这个最佳男主是吧？所以说这是肯定是一个原因，就男主角付出很多。第二个原因就是我刚才说的，你要了解印度的国情，一个电影人在取得了最大的极大的成功以后，开始为社会发生。
是可以的。
同学们，我无数次跟你们说过，我不太提倡你们为社会发声。有几个原因。第一个，你们发声谁听啊，先挣钱吧。
是吧第二呢，你们有时候会为了发生，让整个故事就不好干了。但是我同时也强调过，你如果已经成名了，挣到大钱了，你为社会发生，你是是你的责任。
同学们不要片面理解老师说的话啊，我禁止你们为社会发声，是因为第一你发声没人听。第二，你有时候为了说教，导致你的作品很难看。
这两个原因，但是一旦你赚到大钱了，成了大名了，你还不为社会发生，那是你的问题。所以不要片面的理解说查理老师不提倡电影有教育我不，但是像阿米尔汗这种级别的艺术家，他为整个印度社会而发生这件事情。
功德不良。因为印度14亿人口有7亿妇女，至少其中有5亿生活在水深火热之中吧。所以说这这个是配得上一个高分的，而且这部电影明显瞄着国际化，他要向全世界呼吁揭露是吧？当然了，人家片子还好看，相信啊，这就是社会的良心。
来再探讨一个问题，这部电影或者说体育题材类的电影。哎，这种类型的电影这种类型的片子会写了吧。同学们，我们先来说一下这种这种类型片子的写法啊，首先制定一个目标。
这个目标非常容易理解。然后为了这个目标。
采取一个看似非常合理的行动，然后再到故事终点的时候，否定之前的行动。
也就是说两个行动加一个目标组成这个故事的主干。这种这种结构在我这个最早讲免费课的时候，我就给大家讲过。
我当时用的是want和ne，记不记得？want need就是你先确定一个是吧，然后再来。
两条路径。
那这种类型的片子啊不难写，但是有一个非常棘手的问题。
体育类题材都有一个非常棘手的问题，就是比赛场面。
展示的次数和频率。那这节课给大家留一个作业。
回去数一下，在这部电影里面摔跤都摔了多少次。我可以提前告诉大家，摔的比较多，比起传统的体育片来说摔的比较多。因为所有的体育题材电影都需要处理这个棘肉的问题，就是这个比赛场面，真刀实枪比赛场面，我到底展示多少，我敢不敢展示会调节奏还是会提节奏。
在这部电影当中比比常规体育电影展示的要多很多。
原因当然显而易见，因为摔跤强对抗嘛，你如果是个骑自行车的，有骑自行车的体育类是吧？跑步的那就展示不了这么多了。所以同学们留下这个思考去研究一下，你以后写体育题材的时候，你给我记住，这是个关键点，到底。
他展示了多少次，以及多了还是少了，就会不会显得多。那这节课我们就上到这里啊，学了一部非常好的印度电影。同时呢也知道人家为什么会得高分。我们也知道体育类题材的写法以及难点，我们都学一下啊，以及我其实最近一直给大家讲小环境和大环境、小主题和大主题。
这节课我们深刻的理解下课吧，同学们。
。